today's one minute Monday is how to
instantly turn your day around so this
morning I started off it wasn't the
greatest days okay
I've started off with a buddy of mine
and we're working on something and and
and it wasn't working out while we had
some people collaborating with and and
it just exploded on us and we didn't do
a great job and then I got a call with
somebody who was getting distracted and
we didn't have a the vibe wasn't there
like my morning vibe was screwed up
today it's screwed up today and this
video day I got to make videos for you
guys right I gotta inspire motivate
believe in entrepreneurs and it's hard
when I'm not feeling all jazzed up and
energize myself so here's how I
instantly turn that around are you
feeling the energy now here's how I
turned it around in five minutes okay
first thing I did I grabbed the coffee
now this isn't just any coffee this is
one brought to me by Jason Fonseca and I
feelin the love that went into this so
feelin the love that the kid what is
this Jason what am i drinking caramel
caramel shots coffee so I got the sugar
I got the caffeine I'm feeling the love
from Jason to get me inspired and
motivated next thing I did was I put on
a song I need a sign I need a song he's
gonna make me wanna to grind to dance to
move and and I play the song don't by ed
sheeran the remix version and I'm I'm
shaking it out I'm dancing you gotta
have that in there okay you gotta you
gotta be moving get your body move and
get out of your chair and the third
thing is I remember you guys I remember
your comments remember you guys are
watching this video to get motivated to
believe in yourself to get a little
juice and remembering all the great
feedback that you guys have for our
videos that keeps me excited and wanted
to set me up for an awesome day of video
recordings is the first video record of
the day I'm excited I'm pumped I'm ready
to go that's how I instantly turn my day
around apply it to your business when
you're having a bad day - and believe hi
I'm Tory epsilon from time management
chef calm
mm kaleipus news that their ethnic
subscribe
you